الثاني عشر من اغسطس عام 2003 ينتقل
كريستيانو رونالدو ابن ال 18 الى مانشستر
يونايتد ليكون اغلى مراهق في تاريخ كره
القدم الانجليزيه وتبدا احدى امتع القصص
في تاريخ الكره بشكل عام في كاس العالم
2006 رونالدو ضمن صفوف البرتغال التي
تواجه انجلترا هنا يتسبب في طرد وان روني
زميلي في مانشستر يونايتد ليعود لانجلترا
يواجه هجوم الصحافه واستهجان جماهير
الشياطين الحمر لكنه واصل الموسم وانهى
افضل لاعب في البطوله اشتهر رونالدو بعدم
قدرته في السيطره على غضبه وارتكب حماقات
في الملعب حين غادر رونالدو ناديها عام
2009 غدره الى ريال مدريد ضلت جماهير
يونايتد على امل اللقاء مجددا لكن رحلته
التاليه حطت في ايطاليا لكنه يعود لفريق
الطفوله بعد طول انتظار في سن السادسه
والثلاثين
استقبلوه كما لم يغب يوما ابتلعت الجماهير
مفاوضاتي طوال الصيف الماضي مع افضل انديه
اوروبا سمحته عندما ترك الملعب مغادرا
اعتراضا على عدم مشاركه في احدى مباريات
الدوري وسامحت حتى تراجع مستواه اليوم
وبعد ان خفت السحر وانخفضت اللياقه وظلت
الاقدام طريقها نحو المرمى يقرر رونالدو
جدول انتباه بحوار ناري يهاجم فيه مسئوليه
الفريق بينما لا يزال في صفوفه ويخسر
اولترافيد ربما من الابد